Freddy Krueger has been haunting the
dreams of teenagers since 1984 but the
foulmouthed serial killer didn't just
appear out of thin air and movie team
aren't the only nightmare victims
Welcome To My
Nightmare director Wes cven might have
dreamed up Freddy but it took a whole
team of people to bring him to life the
physical process of transforming actor
Robert England into Freddy Krueger with
layers of latex tubes and the occasional
goat bladder took around 3 and 1/2 to 4
hours going through that lengthy make
application process helped England get
into the heads space to inhabit Freddy
and he drew inspiration from classic
movie Monsters England grew up in Los
Angeles surrounded by the remnants of
old Hollywood as a child he would
accompany his parents to Major Studio
previews where he would see firstr run
films that are considered today's
Classics like Anatomy of a Murder and
The Guns of Navarone it makes sense that
England looked to the Past When
developing his own soon Tobe classic
character as he told the guardian M
Freddy was inspired by Claus kinsky nose
Fatu but also by all the monsters that
La Cheney created Freddy signature
slouch was born out of necessity but it
also had a less Sinister inspiration
actor James Kagney England continued the
way Freddy always stands with his legs
far apart was something I stole from
James Kagney a pose that signifies sheer
power people wonder why Freddy has this
strange posture with his right shoulder
slouched but it was because that claw
was so heavy it weighed me down but I
like the way it made me look like a
cowboy drawing a gun as Wes Craven began
to conceptualize Freddy's look he knew
one thing about famous slasher villains
they all seem to have some type of mask
for Michael Myers it's a mask of William
Shatner's face that's been painted white
in Friday the 13th Jason Vorhees hides
behind a hockey mask and leather face
from The Texas Chainsaw Massacre wears
the face of one of his unlucky victims
according to S fantastique Craven was
taken with the ancient mythological
concept of the Mask he explained almost
all cultures have it in their most
important ceremonies it kind of is a
combination of removing humanity and yet
leaving it there behind the eyes for
Craven who hoped to imbue his nightmare
with a little more personality the idea
of a mask presented a unique problem as
he told vulture I wanted my villain to
have a mask but be able to talk and
taunt and threaten to pull it off Craven
settled on scar tissue from Burns that
creates a type of mask without obscuring
Freddy's ability to emote and express
his feelings thus Freddy's iconic look
was born the only thing to
fear is fear himself once Wes Craven had
designed Freddy Krueger he had to dress
him but this also presented a unique
problem for a shape-shifting nightmare
Spirit the filmmaker had to come up with
something so recognizable that viewers
would understand instantly they were
looking at Freddy even when he wasn't in
his standard form Craven seemed to
instinctively understand something
branding experts harp on about today
that the right color scheme can create a
look so recognizable that audiences
automatically associate it with the
thing they're meant to speaking to C
fantastique Craven said he wanted
Freddy's costume to be obvious no matter
what form he shape-shifted into he was
inspired by the DC Comics hero Plastic
Man as the Director put it he used to
change shape but you could always tell
it was him so I wanted Freddy to be a
shape shifter that could be recognized
from his colors to find the right
palette the filmmaker didn't have to
look much further than his coffee table
Craven read a 1982 issue of Scientific
American that reported that to the human
retina the most contrasting colors are
red and green every good slasher villain
has a signature weapon Leatherface has
his chainsaw Jason Wheels a machete and
Michael Myers uses a kitchen knife
understanding the importance of an
eye-catching weapon Wes Craven wanted to
give Freddy something that tapped into
his audience's most Primal fears it was
Craven's cat that got him thinking about
built-in weapon hands as he later
explained I wanted Freddy's weapon to be
something somebody 1,000 years ago could
have related to Predators like Cave
Bears and saber-tooth tigers and all
those creatures if you look at them
they're just knives hands full of knives
Craven believed that Primal Fear still
lured in the human subconscious the
filmmaker and his team played around
with possible knives to use considering
fishing knives before landing on an
odd-looking steak knife that was flipped
around and given another sharp edge by
the end of the production there were
three versions of the glove with
different scenes and uses in mind the
glove with real blades in it a glove
with myar covered blades to reflect
light and a hard rubber glove for
performing stunts as Robert England
reflected my running joke was I had to
be careful going to the bathroom or I
could change my religion why don't you
reach out and touch someone it's long
been said that you should write what you
know and that's a sentiment that Wes
Craven took to heart as he developed his
film aspects of the dream stalking
Predator were inspired by a freaky
encounter that he had as a child through
his window fedoras were a popular men's
wear accessory during Craven's childhood
but one in particular left a mark on his
young mind while young Wesley was
sleeping he was awoken by a seriously
intoxicated man on the street outside
his window Craven recounted he just did
a mind on me he just basically somehow
knew I was up there and he looked right
into my eyes terrified the child hidden
in his room for what seemed like forever
when it felt safe again he crept to the
window again only to see the man still
standing there before walking in the
direction of his apartment entrance
although the encounter ended without
incidents it stuck with Craven
especially the fact that the creepy guy
was wearing a fedora he decided to give
his monster the same hat as he asserted
the idea of an adult who was frightening
and enjoyed terrifying a child was the
origin of Freddy after his casting as
Freddy Krueger Robert England went on to
become a beloved character actor with a
penion for villainy appear in more than
75 feature films through the years it's
hard to believe that if not for a fluke
of scheduling England's notoriety as an
internationally recognizable movie
monster might not have happened a
classically trained actor England
auditioned for the part of Luke
Skywalker in 1976 after his unsuccessful
audition he came home drank a six-pack
of Heineken and told his couch surfing
pal Mark Hamill about the gig while
Hamill's career took off as a result
England was still struggling to get past
being tip cast as the nerdy character in
1983 he landed a more prominent role as
The Lovable alien resistance fighter
Willie on the miniseries V ultimately
getting promoted to a regular cast
member in its sequels and 1984 series
England was happy enough with the
success of the series telling vulture I
was on the cusp or I thought I was on
the cusp of celebrity the result of
starring as an adorable curly-haired
alien in the miniseries V on NBC
according to England he went in for a
Nightmare on Elm Street because it was
the only audition that fit into his
schedule during the Hiatus impressed
with England's take on Freddy's darker
died Craven gave him the role and the
rest is history we got special work to
do here you and
me internet rumors have long claimed
that Freddy was based on a real world
villain from a 2017 Facebook viral claim
that Freddy hailed from 1800s Ohio to a
2020 version declaring the villain comes
from Oklahoma while these rumors amount
to little more than Creepy Pasta the
story itself does draw some inspiration
from a real life Terror in vulture's
oral history of a Nightmare on Elm
Street Wes Craven explains another
origin for his his deadly nightmare tale
a Los Angeles Times piece about an
immigrant family who lost their son
under unusually horrifying circumstances
the family which had survived cambodia's
Killing Fields under the CH Rouge regime
had immigrated to the United States to
move on with their lives as best they
could but they found this difficult to
do when their young son was plagued by
terrifying nightmares and he ultimately
died in the middle of one according to
Craven the child was worried that if he
fell asleep the dream monster would kill
him the director mused here was a
Youngster having a vision of a hor that
everyone older was denying that became
the central line of Nightmare on Elm
Street according to a 1987 Los Angeles
Times item the anomaly wasn't a one-off
it happened so frequently that experts
gave it the name Asian death syndrome
the times claimed that from April 1983
to January 1987 upwards of 130 refugees
fleeing southeast Asia had died from the
mysterious condition while we don't
normally think of acting as a
treacherous career onset accidents can
happen especially when there are special
effects involved from Twilight Zone The
Movie to the crow there's a shocking
number of horrific tragedies that have
taken place during Film Production
fortunately for fans of Robert England
things didn't turn out nearly as bad as
they could have on the set of a
Nightmare on Elm Street when one crucial
scene didn't go as expected in a tale
recounted by several members of the cast
and crew to Rolling Stone England
surmised the special effects team had
been shooting for about 4 days when it
came time to filmed Johnny Depp's death
scene and he speculated that they may or
may not have been under the influence of
a certain white powder for the bloody
sequence they devised a system to shoot
out hundreds of gallons of red water all
over the room but they overlooked the
insulation on their electrical
components an effects technician went
the wrong way creating a 2-in tsunami of
fake blood all over the electrical
equipment Sparks flew the lights went
out and England took off with Heather
Langan Camp as the actor joked I wasn't
about to save anybody I didn't want to
get electrocuted now I'm playing with
power Freddy might be one of our
favorite villains of all time but few
people would ever want to meet him in a
dark alley even if it means getting to
see one of his coolest tricks in one
Infamous scene in the original Nightmare
on Elm Street Tina steps into the alley
and runs into Freddy who stretches out
his arms before chasing her around and
then finally killing her as far as
slasher Death Scenes go it's one of the
greats thanks in large part to some
pretty spectacular work on the part of
the effects team these days using CGI to
create special effects in movies is
something of a given but back in the
Golden Age of slasher film filmmakers
had to get a little more creative doubly
so in a film series that deals in The
Surreal world of nightmares where the
laws of physics don't quite apply the
special effects team ended up attaching
fishing poles to Freddy's extra long
arms effectively turning him into a
giant marionette to make his knives
spark when he touched the wall a car
battery was connected to his glove and
for the scene's final feat the special
effects team used a revolving room like
the one Fred aair uses to dance across
the ceiling in the 1951 musical royal
wedding